alright our last talk of the morning
session is going to be a nice mix of
algorithms and complexity from Bill
peppermint okay thanks so it's great to
be here and thanks for coming I I know
you have a choice so I'm going to talk
about complete characterization of
unitary quantum space all right so I'm
bill pfefferman a postdoc at quicks in
the university of maryland and this is
joint work with Cedric Lynn who is also
a postdoc at quicks all right so let me
first tell you my motivation which is to
understand the power of quantum
computation with a small number of
qubits okay and in fact our results are
going to show something far stronger
okay we're going to give to natural
problems that completely characterize
the power of quantum computation with
any a priori bound on the number of
qubits okay so the first problem will be
the precise succinct Hamiltonian problem
this is a natural generalization of
cations k local Hamiltonian problem the
second problem will be a
well-conditioned analog of the
ubiquitous matrix inversion problem ok
so these characterizations have many
applications in fact our initial
motivation for thinking about these
issues had nothing to do with space okay
instead what we were trying to do is
answer some particularly basic and
foundational questions about qma proof
systems and Hamiltonian complexity okay
there are other applications such as
well you know trying to understand the
power the comparative power of preparing
pep states versus the ground states of
general local hamiltonians and even to
classical long space complexity okay so
formally what we're really talking about
is quantum space complexity and the
primary complexity class will consider
is called BQ space k of n okay which is
the class of promise problems that can
be decided by a bounded error quantum
algorithm the axon K of N cubits right
so formally speaking will will say that
there exists a uniformly generated
family of quantum circuits QX each of
which acts on
most k of x cubed okay with the property
that if the answer is yes the circuit QX
accepts with high probability say
probability greater than two-thirds
whereas if the answer is no then the
circuit accepts with probability at most
one third this is the BQ the bounded
error quantum part so notice that
nothing nothing really fishy is going on
here if instead of bounding the number
of qubits that the circuit is acting on
we had instead decided to bound the size
of the circuit right by say a polynomial
in n then we would have gotten b QP
instead of DQ space okay but we're not
interested in time complexity as much as
space complexity here which is simply
the number of qubits that each of these
circuits axon ok so our results will
show to natural complete problems for
the class BQ space k of n ok for any K
between logarithmic and N and polynomial
in n ok now reductions will use
classical k of n-space and polynomial
time so I think this is kind of about as
strong as we could hope for the only
subtlety here the only thing that's not
completely standard in all of the space
literature okay is that we're going to
be talking about unitary quantum space
okay which by definition means we're not
going to have any intermediate
measurements we're simply going to apply
our unitary quantum circuit that's Q of
X and we're going to measure some output
qubits we're not going to worry about
intermediate measurements in the
computation right so I think this is a
little this a little bit odd for people
who are used to thinking about time
complexity because we have time
efficient means for deferring
intermediate measurements until the end
of the computation okay but if you think
about how these methods work they
introduce extra and silica vets okay so
they don't in general preserve quantum
space complexity again it's not known if
deferring intermediate measurements can
be done space efficiently ok so the way
we'll handle that in this talk is we'll
just assume that all of the measurements
are at the end but I want to stress that
this is not without loss of generality
ok so I think one of the most
interesting aspects of this talk is that
will connect quantum
space complexity on the one hand with
quantum Merlin Arthur protocols on the
other ok so what are these protocols
these are problems whose solutions can
be verified quantumly given a quantum
state as a witness ok so here's here's
Arthur he's really excited and happy
because he has a quantum computer okay
and he's receiving you know a polynomial
in n qubit quantum states I from merlin
which is supposed to convince him of the
validity of some mathematical claim ok
so formally qma with completeness seed
and soundness s is the class of promise
problems so that if the answer is yes
there exists a polynomial in n cubed
quantum states I that Merlin can send to
Arthur ok that convinces Arthur that's V
the verifier to accept with probability
greater than see that the completeness
all right where is if the answer is no
that no matter what quantum states I
Merlin sends to Arthur Arthur accepts
with probability less than asks the
soundness ok so if we say qma with no
other parameterization we're talking
about qma with bounded errors so
completeness two-thirds soundness
one-third and we know from our
amplification results that we get the
same class as long as the completeness
minus soundness the so-called promise
cap ok is bounded by an inverse
polynomial ok so we get the same bounded
error class ok so I think you know one
of the main reasons to be interested in
qma is Qatar's result that says that the
k local hamiltonian problem is qm a
complete ok so what is this problem
we're given as input a so-called k local
hamiltonian by definition means that the
hamiltonian can be written as a sum of K
local terms each of which you know so
each of these terms H I acts non-trivial
e on at most K cubits and is the
identity on the rest of the space ok and
we're just asked you know we're promised
that either the minimum I ghen value ok
of this Hamiltonian or the so-called
ground state energy is either greater
than B or it's less than a where the gap
B minus a is bounded by an inverse
polynomial in N and is
number of qubits that they Hamiltonian
tax on okay and we just have to decide
which is the case you can think of this
as estimating the ground state energy to
within precision inverse polynomial in n
okay this is our standard prototypical
qm a complete problem I think it
motivates the study of qma right but
we're also going to be interested in
generalizations so the main one will
study is is so-called precise qma so by
precise I mean that the completeness
minus soundness gap is going to be
bounded by an inverse exponential
quantity instead of an inverse
polynomial quantity all right so the
only thing that's really clear about
this class it's completely trivial is
that it clearly contains qma can because
when the gap gets smaller you're not
going to get less powerful ok ok and
then totally generic definition is AK
bounded queue ma m ok which just means
that Arthur's verification circuit axon
k cubits and Merlin sends an M qubit
quantum witness ok so we just say
standard qma would be the case in which
k and m are polynomials and c and s are
you know two thirds and one third the
great so let me tell you about this
first characterization which is the
precise succinct Hamiltonian problem ok
so this like I said it's a natural
generalization of the local Hamiltonian
problem ok so let me tell you about this
problem first I'll define the notion of
succinct encoding ok which is simply you
know we say that a classical Turing
machine M is a succinct encoding for a 2
to the K by 2 to the K matrix a ok if on
input I a row index it spits out the
nonzero elements of the I throw ok you
know efficiently which for us means in
polynomial time and using K of N
classical space ok so now these succinct
encodings don't exist for every matrix
for example if K is a polynomial and so
this the dimension of this matrix is to
to the poly by 2 to the poly ok in
general as having a succinct encoding
will mount to a sparsity condition ok
that there are at most polynomial number
of nonzero elements in each row of the
matrix a
okay so now let me tell you formally
about this K of N precise succinct
Hamiltonian problem we're going to give
us input a succinct encoding of a 2 to
the K by 2 to the cave hermitian matrix
a and we're going to be promised either
that the minimum I ghen value is either
greater than a or less than B sorry
greater than B or less than a excuse me
where the gap B minus a is bounded by an
inverse exponential quantity in K of N
okay so and we want to know which is the
case so they should look really familiar
to us it's it's kind of very similar to
the local Hamiltonian problem which I
just described with kind of 22
differences which will kind of make all
the difference the first is that the
input is succinctly encoded okay instead
of local it's kind of a generalization
of local and to the precision needed to
determine the promise is inverse
exponential in k instead of inverse
polynomial and n okay so that's why by
the way that's why it's called precise
succinct hamiltonian okay all right and
our main result will be that the K of N
precise succinct Hamiltonian problem is
complete for this class BQ space k event
okay so let me describe the proof here
the more interesting direction is the
upper bound showing that the K of N
precise succinct Hamiltonian problem can
be solved in BQ space K of N for
convenience i'll divide this proof into
two parts the first part i'll show that
this problem has a qi precise qm a
protocol okay in which the the
completeness minus soundness gap is
bounded by an inverse exponential in
kiev an okay so what we're going to show
is a qm a protocol with with these
parameters okay so let's just recall
what the the problem was from the last
slide in case you've already forgotten
it we're given its input a succinct
encoding of a 2 to the K by to the cave
hermitian matrix a and we're just asked
to estimate the the minimum augen value
of this matrix a to within precision
inverse exponential in k okay so here's
the qm a protocol we're going to
Merlin to send the eigenstates I that
corresponds to the minimum eigen value
of the matrix a and now Arthur's going
to run phase estimation with 1n Cilic
youbut on the unitary operator e to the
minus I a and Merlin state sigh ok so
here's here's a picture of the circuit
that he applies it's just phase
estimation with one cubit of with 1n
cilic youbut ok and you're simply going
to measure the single n Scylla it's
going to accept if you get zero ok so
why does it work well after all what's
really going on here is this phase
estimation ok with one bit of precision
right so it's not hard to see that we
get the zero outcome with probability
that's just slightly higher ok like 2 to
the minus K higher if the minimal eigen
value of the matrix a is less than
little a then if it's greater than B ok
but this is exactly what we need to
establish the claimed bound ok in other
words precise qma by definition there's
a class of problems in which we accepts
with slightly higher probability in the
yes instance ok when the minimum eigen
value is less than a than in the no
instance when the minimum eigen value is
greater than B ok so despite the fact
that this circuit you know only does
slightly differently on you know
slightly better on the on the yes
instances then of no instances this is
precisely what we need to get this part
of our upper bound which establishes
that this K of N precise succinct
Hamiltonian problem is in this this kind
of precise qma class ok but of course
the remaining question which is
incredibly important is how do we
implement this operator e to the minus I
a ok it's a unitary operator but we're
not given this is input right well we're
given its input is the succinct you know
description the succinct encoding of
this matrix a ok so now we don't need to
implement this exactly ok for this to
work but we need to we do need to
implement this operator with extremely
high precision ok will you do up we need
to implement it with precision 2 to the
minus K you otherwise the error in
simulation of this of this operator
would
completely overwhelmed the gap which is
why we're interested in implementing the
circuit in the first place okay so
luckily we can invoke recent precise
Hamiltonian simulation results of Andrew
childs and collaborators okay to show
that we can actually implement this
operator e to the minus I a to within
very high precision efficiently okay so
we're very lucky that these exist and I
think these are some of the first kind
of applications of these very nice
recent precise Hamiltonian simulation
results okay so so it says that we can
implement these results say that in
general we can implement this operator
to within precision epsilon in space
that scales with log of 1 over epsilon
and time poly log and 1 over epsilon so
notice that this is what we want because
we're interested in implementing this
operator each of the minus I a with
precision you know inverse exponential
in K and we want the space to be bounded
on you know by K okay so it's very
important that the spare the space
especially scales with the log of 1 over
epsilon okay see also the talk on
Thursday for the latest news on these
kind of Hamiltonian simulation results
and but anyway for us the important
thing is using these simulation results
we can implement Arthur's verification
circuit in time that scales polynomial
in N and in K of N space which is
exactly what we're claiming in the first
part of our look of our upper bound ok
good so the second part of the upper
bound is a bit more technical ok and
it's what we're going to show is that
this precise qm a class that we just we
just get you know we just showed in the
last slide is contained in BQ space k of
n ok so this is very much based on the
proof you know modeled after the proof
that qma is in PP if you've seen this
before ok so we're going to start in the
same way which is to error amplify the
precise qm a protocol ok so let me tell
you the goal which is to go from a
precise qm a protocol that has an
inverse exponential in k gap ok that is
the completeness minus the soundness is
inverse exponential and k do a protocol
which has error inverse exponential mkay
okay in other words the completeness is
like 1-2 the minus k and the soundness
is 2 to the minus k okay so this is the
goal but we want to do this while
simultaneously preserving the
verification space at K of N okay so I'm
not aware of any previous methods which
which could kind of have these space
preserving features that we need so we
develop these new these new ideas by
combining ideas from in place
amplification of married and watch rose
okay with ideas with kind of clever
ideas from phase estimation okay so I
want to be very clear what marriott
watros does is it is it allows you to
amplify a generic qma protocol in a way
that doesn't that kind of reuses the
witness so it doesn't change this the
number of qubits that Merlin sons okay
but we need something stronger we don't
only need to be kind of an in-place
amplification that doesn't use more
witness qubits we also want to preserve
our thurs verification space okay so
these are the techniques that we develop
all right so now if we have this this
amplified protocol what we're going to
do is simply consider the same amplified
verification protocol that guesses the
witness okay so we're going to consider
this protocol one on the maximally mixed
State on K of N cube it's okay this is
going to take a huge hit in the
completeness and soundness they're going
to drop considerably but what's not hard
to see is that you know as long as our
original protocol our original error
amplified protocol had error that was
inven verse exponential in K of N we're
going to see that this new kind of no
witness protocol that simply guesses the
witness at random okay it has a precise
gap so the completeness minus the
soundness is bounded by an inverse
exponential in k event okay but now we
have a precise protocol with no witness
and we're simply going to amplify again
by using these space efficient qma error
amplification techniques that we used
before okay that we developed for this
purpose right so this is going to allow
us to obtain a bounded error okay it's
going to blow up our time but the only
thing we really care about is the space
so at the end of the day the space will
remain at k
which establishes the upper bound okay
we also use our space amplification a
space-efficient amplification technique
to prove hardness so we show that K of N
precise Hamiltonian problem precise
succinct Hamiltonian problem is also BQ
spaced k event hard the idea there is we
kind of first amplify the this circuit
and then it kind of follows from kitaev
clock construction to effectively build
a sparse and therefore succinctly
encoded hamiltonian from the amplified
circuit okay all right so why do we care
about this other than you know the
reasons I mentioned earlier so it turns
out i think the most important
application is to understanding the
power of precise qma okay so we show
that precise qma is exactly equal to p
space and so I guess the question we're
asking is how does the power of qma
scale with the completeness minus
soundness bound okay so let's recall
what precise qma was it was the qm a
class in which the completeness minus
the soundness its inverse exponential
okay and it turns out that both upper
and lower bounds follow from the result
i just showed the completeness result
okay together with an older result by
watros which shows that BQ space b QP
space is equal to p space p QP space is
just what I was calling BQ space with
any polynomial and end space bound okay
right so I think an important corollary
of this application is that if instead
of asking as Kataya did to estimate the
ground you know how hard is estimating
the ground state energy of a local
Hamiltonian with an inverse polynomial
precision if instead of that we had
asked how hard is estimating the ground
state of a local Hamiltonian to with an
exponential precision ok we would
actually have gotten a piece based
complete problem instead of a qm a
complete problem okay so another
extension is we can handle this in the
perfect completeness case so in other
words not only do we show that precise
qma is equal to p space but precise qma
in which we have perfect completeness
and our soundness is is you know 1-2 to
the minus poly this is also equal to p
space okay so a corollary is that
checking it for local Hamiltonian as
zero ground state energy is a piece
based complete problem okay all right so
where is this power coming from why is
precise qma equal to P space okay so so
first of all good the power simply come
from the fact that we have a quantum
witness okay so good qma equal precise
qma equal P space because they all equal
P space the answer is unlikely because
qma is known to be in PP so if this if
all of these classes are equal then p
space is equal to P P okay how about for
sale you know how powerful is precise ma
the classical analog of precise qma so
in other words could it be that the
power just comes from this small gap
okay that's nothing to do with quantum
computing well it turns out that you
know crude upper bound on this class
precise MA okay is NP to the pp okay and
I kind of won't get into it but we
really think that strongly that this
does not equal P space it's kind of
strictly less powerful than P space okay
so the power of precise qma seems to
come from both the quantum witness and
the small gap together and not from only
one of these two things in isolation
okay let me say a little bit more about
these precise complexity classes I think
something that's nice about this is we
can answer questions in the precise
regime about complexity theory that we
have no idea how to answer in the
bounded error regime okay so for example
how powerful is qma to this is this qm a
class in which Merlin receives you know
the tensor product of two quantum states
I 1 tensor site to so classically we
really don't know how you know if these
two things are different qma versus qma
too but in the precise regime we just
showed you that precise qma is equal to
p space we also show from an older
results that precise qm a2 is equal to n
x okay so in fact in the precise world
these two classes are probably unequal
okay unless an X was equal to P space
I'm kind of running out of time but I'll
say that we can do something similar
with precise qma that widths you know a
quantum witness with a quantum verifier
versus precise QC
ma which is a you know a quantum
verifier with a classical witness so we
can show that likely in the precise
world these two classes are not equal ok
we can also show that with with perfect
completeness ok in the precise world qma
in a precise qma is equal to precise qma
1 whereas in the bounded error world we
have no idea ok all right let me talk a
little bit about matrix inversion so let
me tell you about the classical
complexity of matrix inversion so here's
the problem I'm talking about we're
given its input an invertible n by n
matrix a with integer entries and will
promise that either a fixed element of
the inverse of a is greater than
two-thirds or it's less than one-third
here we have to decide which is the case
alright so something that's known about
this it goes back to the mid 70s where
Sankey's algorithm says that it can be
solved in classical log squared event in
space okay and so what mysteriously we
don't believe that this problem can be
solved in log n space okay so we kind of
have reason to believe that this log
squared is kind of necessary and
sufficient if we care about space
classical space complexity okay so in
fact if it's solvable in log n space
then L is equal to n L okay it's kind of
the log space equivalent of P equal NP
is we don't believe that the matrix
inversion problem can be solved in
classical space logarithmic and n okay
so a natural question is can we expect
to do better quantumly and a really
really surprising result I think of Tosh
MA from 2012 says that you know kind of
a conditional answer it says that if you
add a well-conditioned constraint on the
matrix okay you say you have the same
problem that we just talked about the
matrix inversion problem but you bound
the condition number the ratio of the
largest to smallest singular value by a
polynomial in n okay then you in fact
can solve this this matrix inversion
problem in you know in DQ space log n in
a non unitary class so the circuit has
intermediate measurements okay but of
course so of course this appears to
obtain a quadratic speed up in space
usage over classical algorithms but it
begs the question how important is this
well conditioned restriction
right so in particular can we use Tosh
mods result as intuition that maybe we
should be able to also solve the general
you know unbounded condition number case
in quantum space log of n ok we're going
to argue that the answer is no so here's
our results we're going to show that in
fact this well conditioned matrix
inversion problem is complete for BQ for
actually unitary BQ space log n okay so
the first result is that we give a new
quantum algorithm for well conditioned
matrix inversion that it avoids
intermediate measurements okay so this
is you know a step up from Tosh MA who
needs intermediate measurement in his
circuit okay but we don't only we don't
only prove the algorithm that's the
upper bound we also prove the lower
brown we show that this is the hardest
problem that can be solved in unitary
quantum space logarithmic and n okay so
i think this suggests that somehow this
well-conditioned miss constraint which
before was somewhat mysterious right
it's actually necessary for quantum log
space algorithms all right so let me
just say that we can generalize this
from a problem about n by n matrices
that uses log n qubits to you know to a
complete problem for the class of Cirque
you know of quantum computation that
acts on k event cubits so it's all show
our third result says that the K of N
well conditioned matrix inversion
problem is complete for BQ space k of em
let me just tell you quickly what this
is we're given as input a 2 to the K by
2 to the K matrix a that it has a
succinct encoding ok just as before and
an upper bound of 2 to the K of N on the
condition number ok and it's the same
question as before in other words you
know is a fixed entry of the inverse of
the matrix ok greater than two-thirds or
less than one-third ok what we can we
have to decide which is the case and we
can show that this is complete 4bq space
k event it's the hardest problem that
can be solved by a quantum computer that
acts on K of n qubits ok
so one more result which I kind of won't
say formally but i think is still
surprising you can read the paper to
figure out all the parameters but you
know so far we haven't been talking
about time complexity we've only been
talking about space complexity okay but
it turns out by varying the dimension
and bound on the condition number we can
use this matrix inversion problem to
actually characterize the power of
quantum computation with simultaneously
bounded time and space okay all right
let me add with some open questions so
can we use this result that I said about
precise qma exactly equaling p space to
give a piece based upper bound for other
complexity classes so i think what we
really want is to understand a good
upper bound for qma too so can we do
this by pushing that qma to is contained
in precise qma okay which would show a
piece based upper bound all right how
powerful is precise qi p this is the q
IP with you know inverse exponential
completeness soundness gap so we don't
know and you know can we give natural
complete problems for non unitary
quantum space okay so we were talking
about unitary quantum space for call
that means that all of the measurements
are at the end of the computation but
can we say something interesting about
the non unitary case okay we don't know
all right thanks
any questions for bill
hey you said something about yet the
same upper bound for precise key cma and
precise ma do you do you know the
relationship between those two classes
at all it's a good question no i don't i
think the best thing i know at the
moment is that there's they have the
same best upper bound it's a great
question to ask what exactly you know
Eve's a relationship other than that and
I really don't know so if you if you
consider more precise Precision's like
cuckoo more doubly special what would
happen do you a door yeah it's a good
question so the question just repeat is
if you consider like what I'm calling
precise precise which is like you know
ee exponential gap and so for qi p okay
we know from a result of wat rose and
collaborators that precise precise qi p
that is qi p with EE exponentially small
you know completeness on this gap that
that's equal to x ok now if we ask about
qma we ask how powerful is doubly
precise qma ok we don't we don't fully
know we know that it's it's somewhere
between p space by our results and x by
the results i just mentioned about qi p
but one thing I can say is that if you
have perfect completeness ok if your
completeness is one and your soundness
is anything less than one okay then we
can show this is also equal to P space
okay but in the non perfect completeness
regime I don't know I have a question
classically you never need to run for
more than exponential time in your space
what is that true in the quantum case
yeah it is it is true it is true in the
quantum case and that's because of the
way we define cut the uniformity
condition okay socially yes the answer
is yes I was confused about that
uniformity condition also because that
the circuits Run For Less the classical
it sounds like the if
I understood correctly that the
classical Turing machine that generates
the circuits runs for less time than the
size of the circuit so that that means
that that is that right and so that
means that the classical circuit is
asked what is the gate at time T in Cuba
died and just spits that out relatively
quickly right exactly ok
yeah beyond you know
what would you say about the
relationship between non unitary and
unitary quantum lock space would you
conjecture that there are same or
whether one is more powerful than the
other right that's that's a really great
question that it's actually kind of the
question I though it was so its meaning
to point out in my last my last open
question right which is that I really
don't have a feel for that so i think
what i can say you know is that we had
one result before we came along that
seemed to indicate that maybe there was
you know some power to be gained from
intermediate measurements right that was
Tosh maas result we just took care of
that result we said that actually you
know we can do just as well without the
intermediate measurements okay so i
think at the moment I don't really have
any reason to think that I don't have a
particular application in mind that
seems to be more powerful with
intermediate measurements but I actually
really don't want to conjecture one way
or the other I don't I don't I have no
intuition for this whether or not that
should actually you know make a
difference that's a good question
I just want to push arms question where
you're saying that somehow you're
forcing the circuit to run in
exponential time but so okay so we move
this universe a bit it's probably there
are ways to handle this right and allow
along so what would you think would like
what's either any advantage running more
than exponential time yeah it's a good
question I mean I so I don't know this
is this with this is this amounts to
what happens if you change the
uniformity condition right the
uniformity condition right now says that
there's some turing machine in the
background right a classical turing
machine that's generating a description
of this trick of this circuit right and
you know at the moment the way we're
defining things you know amounts to the
fact that there's only so many possible
turing machines that could generate this
this this you know quantum circuit okay
which which means that we have a bound
on the maximum size of that circuit so
make it succinctly don't have that right
and we have a much larger quantum
circuit then I could imagine that you
could do more powerful things obviously
hello yeah this is not a question but I
would like to answer that question if
that's okay with you bill sure so that's
the reason why we only consider space
classes up to polynomial space because
if you only consider space classes that
don't use space more than that then you
can with assume without loss of
generality that the classical Turing
machine only uses polynomial time about
that I above that we don't really know
but that's that's the reason why we only
consider up the polynomial time so up
the polynomial space and about that some
of our proofs will break yeah I guess
actually just it sounds like the answer
is going to be this is an open question
but you could imagine outputting a
quantum circuit where you say here the
sequence of gates now repeat these x
times where I'm going to print out X in
binary and then you know actually it
could be quite large actually one
another question which is so you
mentioned that the well-conditioned
problem is complete but it still could
be equivalent to the ill-conditioned
problem right absolutely absolutely
right so I wasn't saying anything formal
about that yeah I think would be
reasonable to conjecture that kind of
you know as the conjecture condition
number grows the problem gets harder but
there's no reason I think there's no
real reason in my mind that I feel that
way it could be that there's a collapse
somewhere but you're sort of times the
fact that it corresponds to different
time and space does that give some
evidence about yeah absolutely I think I
so one way I thought about this when I
was coming up with these results it's
kind of like almost like a space
hierarchy theorem right the kind of you
know it gives some evidence that if you
give me more space more cubit that you
know somehow you can solve it what seems
like a more you know more impressive
problem but I don't like I said I mean
that's kind of an e more intuition than
anything else because there is it could
be that at certain point there's a
collapse in the kind of condition number
hierarchy right at a certain point you
can solve a much much hot you know
hardly what seems like a harder problem
with the ability to solve you know much
lower condition number I don't know how
to roll that out
so are there any results to argue for or
against if we cannot post on the
measurements until the end and do we
gain anything for that or not right so
let's see so I I don't want I don't want
to kind of just repeat things I've
already said but i think this question
really if i'm understanding correctly it
really boils down to you know what power
do I think we have from unitary versus
non unitary quantum space right so for
so and we really don't know so let me
give you let me give you an example so
suppose we have a QM a protocol okay and
we had the verification circuit has
intermediate measurements okay and for
whatever reason maybe because I want to
preserve space you don't allow me to
defer those measurements okay so we're
just stuck with those measurements then
you can ask you know how can I amplify
that that circuit okay and the best
thing we know how to do okay is to just
repeat several times okay so for example
in place amplification the kind of
celebrated result which I talked about
if married in watchos which says that
you can kind of amplify without blowing
up the number of witness qubits right
that that is to assumes access to the
inverse of the verification circuit okay
but notice right if we have intermediate
measurements you know the inverse isn't
well-defined right what does it mean
okay so every the answer really you know
is that everything seems to break we
don't really have good ideas for what to
do in that case now does that does that
imply that there's somehow more powerful
you know more power for the non unitary
case it's possible I don't have any
examples that seem to suggest that
if there are no other questions for bill
then let's thank McGann for a nice talk
[Applause]